Having an assignment to write a research paper
may be in the same category as a dentist telling
you that you need a root canal, neither will be
painless but each can be made less painful when
having a positive attitude and knowing what to
expect. The analogy that writing a research paper
is like a marathon rather than like a sprint
race is frequently used. It’s time consuming,
it doesn't always go smoothly and can even be
painful at times. But understanding and applying
what needs to be done before, during and after
will help you run that research writing race.
This course will help you understand the
writing decisions that will need to be made.
And to anticipate potential barriers, so you
can take steps to either avoid, if possible,
the problem areas, or at least to minimize
them. The writing process is emphasized in
every writing course. As with any process, enough
time needs to be allowed for each step or stage.
The lessons in this course will help you realize
the importance of managing your time throughout
the entire process. Also, all three of the
pre-writing methods are discussed and illustrated.
And then you'll learn how that pre-writing stage
will help you prepare a structured outline.
We'll look at how you can select a research worthy
topic. And how to turn that idea into a strong
thesis statement. And then how to select research
to support that thesis. How much, how to find it,
what sources are credible and how to document
those sources. And finally, the course will
emphasize the importance of the revision process.
So, let’s begin on the research paper journey.
Why is publishing important?
If you're a graduate student,
you may ask yourself, to do or not to
do a PhD? What will happen if I follow
that track? You have just begun your PhD and
wondering how to present your research right.
In which genre should you publish?
For starters, you should know that one
of the main tasks of the researcher is to
spread their work and present it to peers.
We need to understand academia and how publishing
is a very critical component for a researcher
to advance the scientific knowledge.
Publication is a form of expression and
communication. By putting your ideas together
in a resourceful way and publishing it,
it allows you to share your results. If
scientists kept their results in the lab,
there will be no real-world progress.
Publication can also help you feel stronger
about your work by getting important criticism
back from reviewers who are experts in your field.
It also enables you to get familiar with other
academics working on your topic. Furthermore,
if you are thinking about continuing your academic
life, publishing is extremely important. You will
be evaluated in terms of number of publication
and in which kinds of journals you publish. It
contributes to determining salaries, academic
position, contracts, and grants application.
The good things about research is
that there is no one standard way.
This means there are many ways to share your work
and to get published depending on your domain.
The main difference between research
papers and other forms of publishing
is that research papers are often
strengthened by facts and statistics.
There are different types of scholarly literature,
some of which require original research,
also regarded as primary literature, and some
that are based on other published work or known
as secondary literature. It is important to
have a clear idea about the different types of
articles that you can publish in journals. This
will help you understand the ways in which you
can disseminate your work and identify what kind
of article would be suitable for your study.
The types of publications are different in
different fields. For instance, a clinical trial
is possible only in the field of medicine, while
an empirical study is more common in the field of
social sciences. It is important to remember that
not all journals publish every kind of article.
Therefore, most journal publishers
provide prospective authors with
accurate and specific guidelines for
the different articles they publish.
Specifications about the types of articles
published can be found under the guidelines
to authors section on a journal’s website.
If you have a target journal in mind,
you should check whether it publishes the
kind of manuscript you are planning to write.
Some of the possible types of
scientific publications are:
Original research ,
Review article ,
Clinical case study ,
Clinical trial ,
Perspective, opinion, and commentary ,
and Book review.
Original Articles
Original articles are
papers that detailed studies reporting original
research and are classified as primary literature.
They include hypothesis, background study,
methods, results, interpretation of findings,
and a discussion of possible implications. These
normally require a significant investment of
time to collect the primary data
and interpret it conclusively.
Review article
Review articles
provide a critical and constructive analysis
of existing published literature in a field,
through summary, analysis, and comparison,
often identifying specific gaps or problems
and providing recommendations for future
research. These are considered as secondary
literature since they generally do not present
new data from the author's experimental work.
Review articles can be of three types: literature
reviews, systematic reviews, and meta-analyses.
Review articles can be of varying lengths
depending upon the journal and subject area.
Clinical case study
Clinical case studies present the details of real
patient cases from medical or clinical practice.
The cases presented are usually those that
contribute significantly to the existing knowledge
on the field. The study is expected to discuss the
signs, symptoms, diagnosis, and treatment of a
disease. Clinical case studies require a lot of
practical experience and may not be a suitable
publication format for early career researchers.
Clinical trial
Clinical trials describe the methodology,
implementation, and results of controlled studies,
usually undertaken with large patient groups.
Clinical trials often require
practical work experience,
as well as high standards
of ethics and reliability.
Perspective, opinion, and commentary
Perspective pieces are scholarly reviews
of fundamental concepts or prevalent ideas
in a field. These are usually essays that
present a personal point of view critiquing
widespread notions pertaining to a field.
A perspective piece can be a review of a
single concept or a few related concepts.
These are considered as secondary literature.
Opinion articles present the author’s viewpoint
on the interpretation, analysis, or methods
used in a particular study. It allows the
author to comment on the strength and
weakness of a theory or hypothesis.
Opinion articles are usually based on constructive
criticism and should be backed by evidence. Such
articles promote discussion on current issues
concerning science. Commentaries are short
articles that draw attention to or present a
criticism of a previously published article,
book, or report, explaining why it interested
them and how it might be illuminating for readers.
Finally , Book review
Book reviews are published
in most academic journals. The aim of a book
review is to provide insight and opinion on
recently published scholarly books. Book reviews
are a good publication option for early-career
researchers as it allows the researcher to
stay abreast of new literature in the field,
while at the same time, adding
to his publication list.
Which is easier to publish ? An original
research article or a review article?
A review article is generally more difficult
to publish for the simple reason that it is
more difficult to write a good quality review
than a good quality original research paper.
A good review is not just a
summary of the existing literature;
it has to be really critical and should provide
a direction or perspective for future research.
This perspective often develops with maturity and
long standing experience of working in the field.
In fact, some of the best reviews come
from well-respected experts in the field.
However, it also depends on the kind of
review article you are planning to write.
For a narrative review or a literature review,
expertise and experience is more important.
If you are planning to write a systematic
review, you need not be an expert in the field;
if you have a good question, and if
the review is properly performed,
your article will be of good quality. But then
again, a systematic review takes a lot of time.
If you are thinking in terms of easy
publication, I would say an original research
article will be a better choice than a review
article. However, remember that what matters
the most is the quality of your research and how
well you have presented it in your manuscript.